après l'intégration l'immigration des
immigrés l'éducation est un des grands
thèmes de cette campagne présidentielle
le socialiste michel rocard estime qu'il
faudrait d'ailleurs évité de là confié
un ministre mais là rattaché directement
au premier ministre qui n'aimerait lui
une personnalité extérieure chargé du
problème
évitant ainsi les réformes politiques
qui n'ont selon lui jamais vraiment
aboutie
monsieur raymond barre parlait lui aussi
cet après midi près de paris d'éducation
mettant l'accent sur la formation
professionnelle l'autonomie des
universités et les relations entreprises
éducation nationale lorraine 15 je ne
vais pas vous proposer une solution vira
je ne voudrais pas vous proposer une
réforme dans l'espoir qu'elle puisse
porter mon nom je ne voudrais pas non
plus vous proposez loi providentiel la
congeler montbard c'est clair le système
éducatif ne changera pas à coup de
grandes réformes centraliser le candidat
à l'élection présidentielle préfère
définir une stratégie du changement avec
cinq grandes orientations élever le
niveau de formation réduire l'échec
scolaire décentraliser le système
éducatif prendre les universités
autonomes et dégager des moyens
financiers sur plusieurs années problème
du financement
il faut dire les choses ferment
l'éducation est une priorité
elle aura besoin de davantage de moyens
le budget de l'état devra les fournit on
ne sacrifie pas au profit d'objectifs
souvent électoraux la formation de la
jeunesse de france
au sein de ces orientations trois points
particulier retient l'attention de
raymond barre premier point et priorité
des priorités améliorer l'école
élémentaire en amont du système
second point valoriser l'enseignement
professionnel à cet égard la solution
d'avenir réside pour lui dans une
véritable co gestion de cet enseignement
pro gestion par l'état les entreprises
et les organisations professionnelles
troisième point enfin toute l'évolution
du système éducatif repose selon lui sur
une réelle autonomie accordée aux
établissements scolaires